(slow comical variety show music)
♪ It must be love ♪
- Babe?
- [Babe] Yeah?
- (sniffing) Can you smell this?
Um, I'm gonna-- I'm gonna get fries.
Do you want fries?
- Oh, I probably shouldn't.
- Okay.
(doorbell ringing)
- Can I have a fry?
(grumbling)
(sighing contently)
Okay, goodnight.
- Why?
- Still up?
- Should we make something
healthy for dinner tonight?
- Yeah, sure and tomorrow
we'll just go to outer space
and have like (bleeping profanity)
dinner with some aliens.
- Did you just check him out?
- (stuttering) Oh please.
You know you're the only thing
I want to spread all over me.
- I'd (bleeping profanity) that hottie.
Kill the bug!
- What are we going to do?
- Call the police!
- Call your mom!
- My mom? You know we're
not talking right now.
(screaming)
Is it just me or is it kind of cute?
- Oh, it is kind of cute.
Maybe we should keep it as a pet.
- Maybe, maybe not.
- Don't get too close!
Hey, how you doing?
- Oh, I'm a-- I just
ate a bean burrito, so,
maybe tomorrow morning, you know?
- Oh, I don't mind if you toot a little.
It's just the sound of love.
- Hmm.
Well, okay. But no butt stuff.
- Oh, were you going to shower?
I was going to shower.
- [Butter] Then why're you on the couch?
- We could shower together.
- Oh (bleeping profanity) yeah.
(grunting)
- Stop stealing the blanket.
- I'm not stealing it.
I'm defending against
when you steal it later.
Aww. (content sighing)
♪ It must be love ♪
♪ It seems that only I can see ♪
♪ The love she has for me ♪
♪ It must be love ♪